[Musique]
bon ce bon soir là j'ai été étonné parce
qu'il y avait encore le compte à rebours
qui étaient là-bas soir bienvenue dans
le grand studio du figaro on est en
direct donc on est avec vous on attend
vos points de vue c'est figaro live et
donc en attend vos commentaires
après l'annnonce du test positif des
manuels macron oco vide alors est ce que
on en parle trop est ce que le président
a manqué de prudence
est ce qu'après tout bas il est le
président donc il fait un petit peu ce
qu'il veut il a des privilèges que
d'autres n'ont pas on en débat ce soir
avec sophie de menthon bonsoir sophie
présidente d'ethic et chefs d'entreprise
battus parfois abattus jamais attendent
toujours
je voulais contribuer au cas où vous
voudriez modifier votre profil twitter
face à vous le jeune et prometteur
adrien matou journaliste à marianne et
auteur de l'indispensable mélenchon la
chute comment la france
insoumise s'est effondré il faut que
vous offriez au goulot frier à noël
c'est aux éditions du rocher adrien un
petit mot peut-être d'une femme à
laquelle vous avez rendu hommage
c'était émouvant d insister sur twitter
coralie delaume plume de marjah les
figures intellectuelles du souverainisme
alors elle est morte cette semaine d'un
cancer à 44 ans le figaro lui a rendu
hommage sous la plume notamment
d'alexandre ii vecchio le meilleur
hommage a dit son ami david cayla cessé
de lire ses livres
par quelle lubie folie il faut commencer
moi je dirais que peut-être sont plus
réussis c'est le couple franco allemand
n'existe pas puisque c'est un petit peu
un livre à l'image de coralie c'est à
dire que on nous serine beaucoup de
choses en boucle sur le partenaire
allemand sur beaucoup de choses et
coralie c'est quelqu'un qui est à la
fois contre la pensée
unique mais à la fois très rigoureuse
très pédagogue et je pense que le couple
franco allemand n'existe pas c'est
peut-être le livre qui illustre le plus
la qualité de son travail
le couple franco-allemand de coralie
delaume donc c'est le meilleur hommage
qu'on peut rendre à coralie delaume
c'est de lire ce livre il ya un débat
dans lequel coralie delaume aurait
brillé de mille feux c'est celui que
nous aurons ce soir la france at-elle
trop protéger son économie
j'attends vos points de vue mais d'abord
donc cette information une table tombée
ce matin
en milieu de matinée et même à kron a
donc été testé au positif au co vide
alors toutes les infos sont à retrouver
sur la live texte du figaro c'est
l'ensemble la séquence la plus lue ces
dernières heures sur le site du figaro
twitter est saturé de postes sur la sur
la question moi j'ai envie de vous dire
macron est positif et alors bah oui je
dire un peu pareil parce que ce n'est
pas non plus là on peut comprendre que
les gens s'intéressent à ça comme de
manière générale les gens s'intéressent
à tout ce qui relève de la vie privée
des responsables politiques
après les conséquences du fait que
macron attraper le vide sont quand même
assez limitées quoi il va être à
l'isolément pendant environ sept jours
rien ne va changer à part si la
contaminer l'ensemble des plus grands
personnages de l'état et qui avait forme
grave ce que je ne souhaite évidemment
pas il n'y a pas de ce n'est pas une
nouvelle
d'accord en versant si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord c'est une nouvelle d'abord moi
j'ai peur pour brigitte donc avec lequel
elle s'est isolée c'est ce que révèle le
à le figaro madame mal sur le site
justement de retrouver ensuite de sa non
ce qui est important d'abord il ya
beaucoup de chefs d'état qui ont été
touchés dont trump le premier qui a dit
que c'était rien a eu un traitement
incroyable et c'était plutôt grave
l'italie à l'hôpital
donc d'abord il faut quand même saluer
ils prennent des risques je dire
bonjour et l'isoler d'aller et je pense
que il faut saluer le fait qu'ils
prennent des risques je dire ils font
pas attention
ils prennent des risques et tout le
temps ailleurs aussi bien en étant dans
la foule que contaminants en revanche
j'ai un peu la crainte que les français
qui détestent j'ai des privilèges
considère que le dîner qu'il a eu avec
une douzaine de personnes à l'elysée
avec une salle avec une table de 15
mètres de long je crois avec toutes les
précautions possibles
les invités sont partis à minuit il
était pas encore on savait pas encore
qu'il avait locaux vides et voilà alors
on peut se poser des questions et on
coupe tout de suite c'est exactement à
que dit christophe ce qu'on peut dire
maintenant c'est que le président ne
respecte pas
l'arrière est ce que je dis pas ce que
je fais alors non il faudrait quand même
préciser que les gestes barrière il
était là bon faut pas exagérer ses
parents et ses gigantesques tout cas oui
ce nom mise et eilat audi s'amuse pas et
tous les mecs derrière médecin l'elysée
en revanche les adductions si c'est ma
force c'est que les gestes barrières ont
été associés
non mais c'est ce que disent que diam's
est ce que c'est la communication
directe lui fera dire le contraire d'un
chrono mais quand on connait l'elysée
quand on connait tous connais les mecs
qui sont derrière les de 15 m c'est plus
facile qui en matière de protocole à
l'elysée vous avez à sophie par cette
mesure est oui et mais en revanche
conférences et compréhension point de
vue on renvoie les internautes qui
n'auraient pas écouté mais voilà vous
avez été mariés notamment un responsable
du protocole celle de l'elysée et donc
j'ai vraiment de la place en revanche
que je ne comprends pas évidemment qu'il
a le droit de faire et il a des journées
de dengue évidemment ils ont travaillé
ça dit d'être travail
il a droit de travailler jusqu'à minuit
oui personnellement je pense que oui
mais tous les français vous dire à ma
voix là nous on n'a même pas le droit et
luis salom enfin
alors que les restaurants sont fermés
faute voilà le chemin évidemment bon il
ya la passion pour l'égalité des
français pour laquelle j'ai plus de
sympathie peut-être que sophie jacques
faty pour moi j'en ai pas mal donc cette
passion pour l'égalité pour être clair
c'est pas le watergate
c'est pas de scandale d'état et il est
évidemment alors je n'ai pas dire
légitime mais il est naturel peut-être
que que le chef de l'état ne soit pas
astreints aux mêmes contraintes que le
français ordinaires ceci dit on peut
quand même aussi penser qu'il ya une
forme d'exemplarité à avoir quand on est
un responsable public et il faut le dire
même si encore une fois ce n'est pas le
scandale de l'année inter ajoutant
maintenant le couvre feu c'est pour le
chien messi mais honnêtement mais il
faut il faut aussi peut-être salué un
petit peu le l'esprit de s'attirer
d'impertinence des français qui sont pas
soumis à ces dirigeants walesa lui
rallié journée non mais je trouve que le
fait de rater toute la journée a
engendré quelques constats corse positif
pour le pays
on va en discuter parce ultra tout à
leur symbolique sur le sujet mais en
tout cas voilà les français aiment bien
brocardé se moquer et ses tournées en
dérision je pense pas qu'il soit
vraiment prêt à envahir l'elysée pour ça
mais c'est vrai que quand on demande la
perversité pas quelque chose de plus
profond qui est posée dans un exemple de
régulation qui est que ce sont des
contraintes qui sont est sur toi rentre
qu'il pèse sur des libertés publiques et
en plus on a critiqué l'infantilisation
des français voilà bah en fait disons
que restreindre à ce point les
conditions de vie peut être légitime on
peut le justifier
mais on le rend d'autant plus
justifiable qu'on respecte semaine c'est
serré gueulard et qu'on donne pas
l'impression qu'il ya des règles pour
les uns et des règles pour les autres
alors alors pour le dire aussi qu'à pas
quelqu'un qui est privé de plus de
liberté que préside la république
il peut pas sortir il peut pas faire de
courses il les contrats toute la journée
ibos nuitées jour il n'est pas aux 35
heures aussi on peut râler
et
je pense qu'il a le droit de travailler
tard et de se faire servir à repas bon
il trouve que c'était un dîner de
travail
mais c'est évident il ya un couvre-feu
c'était évident tous les fronts ciel
aller râler et si j'étais lui je
l'aurais pas fait alors à l'horaire le
sais plus le nom de personne puisque
l'horaire il ya là un mois je crois que
c'est leurs objections sont faits oui en
ce moment par vous par qui nous regarde
et on continue à des votes moi j'ai une
objection à vous faire aussi bien nicole
à christophe ou bien cet internaute qui
nous dit un dîner qui nous dit que
l'elysée n'est pas un établissement est
essentielle
précisément l'elysée c'est un
établissement est essentielle et
justement est-ce que c'est pas ce pas
partie des prérogatives justement du
président de la république d'échappée eh
bien parfois la règle commune parce que
il à ces responsabilités là mais c'est
une évidence
dîner 80 personnes par personne
peut-être à personne mais personne ne
dirait que le président doit être payé
au smic ou travailler 35 heures comme
disait sophie mais là je suis pas
vraiment sûr le côté tatillon du fait
que les règles doivent s'appliquer à
tout le monde même si à mon avis c'est
un principe général qui est une très
bonne idée j'ai déjà pour les
journalistes du couvre-feu s'applique
pas dans ce cas
non je vais considérer comme journée
l'idée de dérogations qui qui va alors
si vous avez une carte de presse c'est
la question que la réponse soit la
réponse sofia des plus alors et la rue
fait on est on est plus sur la
communication n'est plus sur le symbole
est une vie honnêtement j'ai sous les
yeux la liste des gens qui ont participé
au dîner
est-ce qu'il était absolument vital que
thierry solère ou stéphane séjourné
participaient et viennent égayer droit
de retrait d'aller d'abord je me demande
pourquoi ils viennent d'intégrer
l'elysée et ils viennent d'intégrer
l'elysée que son épaule celle des
collaborateurs du président mais pas ce
que je veux dire c'est que il était dit
son conseil son cancer dont les
conseillers politiques
thierry solère et des conseillers
politiques pour la gestion avec la
droite et steffen seibert a essayé
politique pour jouer baron noir avec
l'agglo mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que encore une fois tout en rappelant
que c'est pas un scandale
est ce que ça aurait changé
brass tiquement la donne que trois ou
quatre participants de la réunion soit
peut-être à distance
au téléphone ou autre à mon avis devrait
pas changer grand chose donc qu'elle ait
beaucoup parce que je comprends très
bien venu en ce que je peux partager et
du coup je comprends pas votre position
n'est pas le droit est ce que vous
pouvez répondre à christoph je trouve
que cette question est très intéressante
mais si elle cette île elle est un peu
ironique qui imagine le général de
gaulle ne pas respecter les règles qu'il
impose aux autres je pense que le
général de gaulle la poutre pouvait ne
pas respecter des règles imposées aux
autres
oui elle alors ceci dit c'était
l'essence même de cette conception de la
fonction présidentielle
one ont par exemple on peut nuancer sur
général de gaulle le général de gaulle
par exemple n'a jamais utilisé les fonds
de l'état
il était très scrupuleux sur la
séparation entre ces dépenses privées et
les dépenses de l'état
c'est quelqu'un touche et que sa pension
de général
oui bien sûr mais à mon avis il me
toucher sa pension général n'a pas
touché de voir didier pas à dîner marron
c'était pas des agapes et alors là non
mais c'est pour ça que moi ce que ma
position elle est simple elle de dire
qu'on ne va pas faire un scandale de ça
mais d'un côté je ne vais pas non plus
me scandalise et si le peuple français
dans sa grande tradition satirique un
peu impertinente
voilà ce qui ricanent des turpitudes
emmanuel macron qui repique sud ouest
y'a pas une turpitude des règles sont
reposés à tout le monde
ils les transgresse il attrape locaux
vides bon ça fait un peu rigoler ce
n'est pas non plus voilà je me
scandalise pas on dit d'un côté ni bas
il n'ya pas attraper le cubi de dîner il
la veille en tout cas ils l'avaient mais
en tout cas il s'est soustrait aux
règles qui soient imposées à tout le
monde sophie factuels pour lui à des
internautes qui disent que vous êtes
trop l'avocate devant le mcs a j'ai pas
du tout l'avocate je dis que c'est une
bourde ce qu'il aurait dû penser qu'il y
aurait des réactions
donc je pense que c'est une gaffe et je
pense parce que effectivement vous
l'avais dit la tradition du peuple
français c'était évident tout le monde
allait se jeter là dessus donc je pense
que c'est une erreur
même si il peut travailler jusqu'à 11
heures et se faire servir un plateau
avec un collaborateur en revanche non je
défends pas eu une boule mais mais en
revanche est absolument nos critiquable
de faire un dîner de travail
la question sur cet aspect là emmanuel
macron quelle communication vous parliez
des conséquences il va pas beaucoup de
concéquence quel concept quelle
communication selon vous il faut autour
et bien de la séquence maintenant c'est
à dire du traitement des manuels macron
à l'internaute disait que les médias
c'était plus indulgent avec macron
qu'ils ne l'ont été avec johnson et
trump
en tous les cas ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'on a beaucoup communiqué sur le
traitement qu'on reçu johnson et trump
est ce que ça doit être le cas pour vous
au regard de de la communication on
regarde delà des banques des règles
démocratiques
la part des médias je pense que le
traitement milliards non sophie de
menthon et non aussi le traitement
médiatique envers trump n'a pas le droit
d'informer justement s'y prendre la
chloroquine par exemple qu'on ne peut
pas le dire enfin c'est ça le truc je
pense honnêtement je pensais que vous
parlez du traitement médiatique lors du
traitement du traitement que va avoir
macron par rapport pas pour ça me
choquerait pas qu'on soit informé
ceci dit il ya quand même le secret
médical savoir si emmanuel macron
refusent de se faire vacciner par
exemple ça me semblera plus intéressant
pardonnez moi c'est une vraie question
figurez vous que je me suis demandé que
se passe-t-il lorsqu'au vaccine
quelqu'un qui est positif qu'il ne sait
pas vous est positif vous avez au co
vide et au vox in the pense que la
première des choses aurait été de nous
informer est-ce que c'est dangereux pour
la personne qu'on vaccine en aucun cas
c'est un traitement curatif puisque
c'est avec ça donc c'est assez
intéressant jeu en revanche c'est ce
qu'on va vacciner brigitte macro avant
tout le monde sait ça fait partie des
questions effectivement qu'ils sont qui
peuvent êtres qui peuvent être posées
sur la question est-ce qu'ils venaient à
regarder certains arrivent justement par
rapport aux personnes publiques
bon ici par exemple on a une règle ce
qu'on ne touche pas à la vie privée
quelques et quelle qu'elle soit mais sur
la sur la ville enjeu politique majeur
du roi appartient à tout le monde
la difficulté c'est cette existence de
deux corps du roi et par exemple sur la
question du vaccin on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de français qui se posent des
questions sur le vaccin
évidemment que si un certain nombre de
responsables politiques rendre public le
fait qu'ils se vaccine ça va inciter les
gens à le faire alors selon nicole tout
cas c'est ce qu'affirme nicole macron a
dit que s'il était positif
il ne prendrait pas de chloroquine
s'était pas encore c'est une question
complètement théorie un grand pas et
j'espère qu'il sera fidèle à ses propos
pourquoi qu'est ce que ça peut nous
faire
et alors là aussi qu'est ce que ça peut
faire à partir du moment où c'est un
traitement qui a été rejetée par l'état
par le ministre de la santé en personne
effectivement il y aurait qui est
considéré comme dans n'importe quel
médecin peut prescrire ce médicament
c'est vrai que officiellement pour ce
cas précis il était déconseillé mais on
n'a jamais interdit aux médecins de
prescrire un médicament on a pas le
droit d hier et donc aux prescrits de la
quinine aux gens normalement de la
chloroquine je fais une parenthèse moi
je n'ai aucune opinion je n'étais pas du
tout particulièrement favorable à la
chloroquine qui n'avaient pas de test
contradictoires enfin il semble qu'ils
aient des continents entiers qui se
remettent à la chloroquine donc on n'en
sais absolument rien voilà peu importe
la façon dont il va être soigné une
autre question qui peut être poser une
question subsidiaire je sais que marie
amélie vient de me dire c'est la mi
temps il faudrait qu'on aborde le
deuxième débat mais il ya quand même
cette idée c'était à l'origine ce que on
avait ce dont on avait prévu par les
cette idée qui est dans l'air et qui est
justement porté par certains députés de
la majorité mort seul est certes mais de
la majorité quand même donc là c'est une
députée udi je vous propose d'écouter
cet cet élu est la proposition qu'elle
fait
nombre de nos concitoyens expriment une
forme de défiance envers les nouveaux
vaccins développés
la personne qui ose dire c'est ma
liberté de ne pas me faire vacciner
ça veut dire qu'elle compte sur les
autres pour empêcher la circulation du
virus
nous pourrions aussi prendre exemple sur
l'israël qui octroie à chaque personne
vaccinée un passeport vers leur
permettant de se rendre dans des lieux
de culture au restaurant en définitive
de retrouver une vie normale
notre groupe considère qu'une telle
mesure serait de nature à inciter les
français à se faire vacciner
ferra pas la question c'est de faire un
passeport vert si vous voulez dire qu'on
vous oblige pas vous vacciner mais vous
devriez avoir un passeport vert qui dit
si vous avez de vic signer ou pas et si
vous n'avez pas été vaccinés vous ne
pouvez pas aller au restaurant vous
pouvez pas aller au théâtre parce que
vous n'avez pas été vaccinés c'est
scandaleux
votre point de vue assez d'accord moi en
tout cas personnellement je suis assez
d'accord parce que à partir avant ou
vaccin est sûr et validé par les par les
autorités combien de temps on soit sûr
alors ça c'est toute la question est
évidemment on n'est pas spécialiste on
peut pas trancher mais j'ai la faiblesse
de penser que si l'état proposant un
vaccin il aura quand même été vérifiée
suffisamment et dans ce cas là bas moi
j'avoue que ça m'agace ray que quelqu'un
que dès que des gens refusent
catégoriquement de se faire vacciner
ça c'est l'horreur c'est leur droit mais
qu'ensuite ils viennent contaminer
d'autres personnes
vous savez que le vaccin n'empêche pas
de vous contaminer
vous savez que vous êtes vacciné vous
êtes protégé par le vaccin
et ça n'empêche pas du tout que vous
contaminer les autres
oui bien alors dire non mais en plus de
ça il ya plein de choses qui sont très
intéressantes vous tabriquet plus
d'anticorps après 80 ans donc vous êtes
vacciné mais y'a pas d'anticorps donc si
compliqué et je pense que la restriction
des libertés ont évoqué tout à l'heure
c'est pas supportable et pire les gens
allergiques
alors donc vous avez un vaccin vert bleu
lors des exceptions sa déception je
donne un dernier mot ben justement posé
la question sur twitter sur la stratégie
de vaccination du gouvernement est ce
que vous pensez que c'est la bonne est
pour l'instant
vous êtes une large majorité à ne pas
trouver qu'elle est bonne je donne
encore là vous donne à la parole encore
sur les commentaires plus sur justement
donc le test positif qui concerne le
président de la république
cet internaute qui dit ce n'est pas le
problème de la légitimité du dîner de
travail mais de la crédibilité de ceux
qui nous dirigent et des règles imposées
et nicole
je pose cette question est ce qu'on va
devoir porter un signe distinctif si on
n'est pas vaccinée
là
stratégie de vaccination adoptée par le
gouvernement est elle la bonne
je crois que julie est en train de me
donner les derniers chiffres est
effectivement là c'est non 51% mais
c'est beaucoup plus partagés que ce
qu'on avait vu tout à l'heure comme
comme comme chiffres il ya une autre
question qu'on pose sur twitter on est
désolé on a fait une faute de syntaxe à
nous a été reproché donc je vous
présente nos excuses mais la question
c'est pensez vous que la france
à trop protéger son économie et c'est là
où il y avait justement c'est la
question qu'on vous a montré tout à
l'heure on vous pose cette question à la
suite d'un livre paraît-il briand qui se
lit très bien
il s'appelle le virage manqué il est aux
éditions manitoba et dans le figaro
aujourd'hui le brillantissime charles
jaigu fait la recension de cet ouvrage
écrit par donc deux historiens de
l'économie donc cela retrouver soit dans
la version envoyée dans la version print
ici soit effectivement bien sûr sur le
site du figaro la thèse c'est que la
france a sacrifié son industrie son
dynamisme économique pour sauver le
pacte social de 45 et cher à adrien à
tous alors charme nous dit ce livre
ausculte sans pitié la culture
viscéralement protectionniste du pays
alors ma question est la suivante est ce
que selon vous la france et a été ces 50
dernières années particulièrement
protectionnistes j'attends vos points de
vue et la question encore plus provoc
c est ce que le protectionnisme tue ou
sauver l'économie j'aimerais bien vous
donner deux heures je suis officier
adrien pour débattre de cela vous allez
avoir un peu moins de dix minutes
d'abord première question est ce que on
peut dire que la france a été
protectionnistes ces 50 dernières années
disons depuis 1945 sophie je n'aurais
pas utiliser le mot protectionnisme
parce que nos frontières soient ouvertes
donc c'est détourner le mot est-ce
qu'elle a été trop protectrice peut-être
des salariés ce qui est tout à fait
différent ensuite il faut distinguer la
période des cinquante dernières années
et la période de la crise là on à
déverser des tombereaux d'argent c'est
pas le même sujet donc pas celui là
pardonnez moi je coupe tout de suite
vous avez vous avez vous dit on a été
peut-être trop protectrice mais en tous
les cas depuis les 50 dernières années
on n'a pas été trop protectionnistes
alors protectionnistes non mais on a été
faussement égalitariste en espérant le
communisme a toujours été une belle idée
en espérant que tout le monde il fallait
niveler au maximum on s'est battu sur
les gros salaires on a alors que le seul
sujet c'était le coût du travail
on a un coût du travail exorbitant par
rapport à tous les pays du monde
ça a été l'un position avec une mauvaise
répartition donc moi si la répartition
avait été bonne si on était capable
d'inciter à bosser si on encourager pas
le chômage très bien mais ce qu'on a
voulu être une politique sociale qui
prélevaient beaucoup qui tapait sur les
riches qui prélevaient beaucoup sur les
riches qui sont partis ou le sait bien
avec un coût du travail trop élevé c'est
raté
c'est raté on est on a été mauvais alors
c'est pas ce que j'appelle protection'
bas quand donc sur ce plan là vous êtes
d'accord déjà c'est pas le procès on n'a
pas été protectionnistes depuis 1945 en
france ça serait compliqué de dire qu'on
était protectionnistes vu qu'il ya après
aucun protectrice en france depuis qu'on
est dans l'union européenne et même
avant je parle même avant de la période
de bien est ce que 2 par exemple entre
la jeunesse 145 1957
on a été trop protectionniste parce que
justement alors le livre j'ai lu
attentivement l'article dans le dans le
figaro sur ce livre dont je suis apprend
d accord avec toutes les thèses le livre
se se concentre sur le virage qu'on
aurait manqué en 74 coups pouces est en
désaccord avec toutes les thèses
pourtant la thèse c'est quand même de
dire que
la force d'une économie elle repose sur
son industrie bien sûr on a sacrifié est
je pense pas qu'on ait sacrifié
industrie de la même manière que les
auteurs du livre donc alors ok le mas le
lièvre date le l'erreur originelle
française de 1974 et de la parole à
l'orgie ce cas là nous avons de la
parole de giscard dans le débat face à
mitterrand
vous n'avez pas le monopole du coeur
exporté exporté cela aurait dû être
l'obsession nationale on ne le fit pas
par peur des efforts qu'il faudrait
demander aux français est imposé au très
puissant parti communiste
ok alors d'être là juste citer mais ça
c'est faux aussi d'accord avec vous je
veux juste citer le fonde le fond de mon
idée c'est que les auteurs du livre
vivre dans un monde parallèle je vous
donner quelques noms quand même depuis
qui qui qui gouverne la france depuis
depuis 50 ans vous avez valéry giscard
d'estaing donc le président du soviet
suprême
jacques chirac le grand timonier c'est
vrai que milo l'erreur disait que
c'était le petit télégraphiste doit il
vraiment mais bon le grand leader
bolchévique bien connu edouard balladur
nicolas sarkozy le petit père des
peuples
emmanuel macron le lider maximo donc on
est on est dans un monde parallèle en
fait où c'est le bolchévisme kiki qui
gouverne en france depuis 40 ans on n'a
pas du tout fait des exonérations de
cotisations sociales qui atteignait déjà
il ya dix ans 23 milliards d'euros
j'imagine même pas commencer aujourd'hui
alors on n'a pas du tout a répondu la
réponse
la réponse de sophie de menthon et puis
je vous relance fait alors vous avez
raison c'est vrai que les noms caisse
mais nous allons aussi se fait par
adrien font pas partie des gens qui
avaient fréquenté beaucoup la fête de
l'humanité
oui mais à la limite il avait un tel
complexe par rapport à la gauche par
rapport à l'arrêt de cette fameuse
répartition que ils n'ont jamais été
vraiment libéraux que ils n'ont jamais
confiance dans l'entreprise qui a été
très mal vu souvenez-vous le cnpf on a
été vue de changer de nom tellement
c'était mal vu c'est devenu une mode fc
pas mieux
c'est le sigle le plus détesté de france
où le savoir donc l'entreprise s'était
mal c'est l'exploitation de l'homme par
l'homme
on a gardé
complet de logiciels magicienne marxiste
pas forcément marxiste et ne le pouvez
pas on a quand même libéré les prix
extrêmement tard c'est raymond barre qui
a libéré le prix de la baguette et puis
on a 40 ans oui ça fait quand même 40
ans mais c'est pas beaucoup je pense que
on n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait on n'a
pas été la france n'est pas un pays de
libéral n'a jamais été un pays libéral
et donc c'est vrai que ceux qui ont été
plus libéraux ont réussi mieux leurs
économies on voit on voit l'allemagne on
voit les autres et ses skis mois ce qui
m'attriste que cocom accroc disent aimer
comment on dépense à pognon fou il a été
très mal interprété c'est vrai qu'on
dépose sa pognon fou pour un mauvais
résultat on a un semis qui se rapproche
du salaire moyen en france c'est
dramatique mais je refais une objection
à vous deux c'est que vous avez cité un
certain nombre de gens bon effectivement
qui était pas communiste mais qui était
pour beaucoup
hormis nicolas sarkozy des hauts
fonctionnaires à ça et est ce que
justement il n'y a pas et là aussi
certains de vos amis peut être
des gens comme vous sophie ont soutenu
par exemple quelqu'un comme nicole les
modèles mâcon qui hormis une incursion
dans la banque mais n'a jamais pour
reprendre l'expression de jerry
goldsmith qui parlait des libéraux des
libéraux idéologie qui dit ces gens là
n'ont jamais su comment était une
entreprise est ce qu'on n'a pas eu
justement il ya un espèce de trompe
l'oeil vie c'est-à-dire des des hauts
fonctionnaires qui n'ont jamais connu
l'entreprise qui ont eu parfois un
discours très libérale et une action
qu'ils n'étaient pas les seuls qui ont
connu un peu lente reprise c'était
pompidou c'était encore la banque
parce que je considère pas non plus que
la banque s'est vraiment l'entreprise
bien que ce soit tout à fait utile
estimable donc on a alors je vous
signale comme mon ami c'est pas bon oui
on a ce mal profond qui a été le même
pour les masques pour les tests etc
on a cet état profond gérés par des
énarques tous les administrations sont
gangrénés personne ne le dirige dites
moi quel est le chef de l'administration
ils peuvent tous bloqués ils ont un
pouvoir de dire non et on a une
administration qui a une sensibilité
alors j'aime pas dire gauche droite se
veut rien dire parce que la droite était
pas libéré de nombreux communistes au
communisme est en tout cas étatiste
social et qui n'avait aucune confiance
dans tout ce qui était le monde de
l'entreprise alors écoutez moi je vais
peut-être me livrer peut-être une petite
défense de l'état bon je connais le
débat vu et revu sur les hauts
fonctionnaires qui ne comprennent rien
je connais les administrations mais que
c'est quand même ça qui est un soulevé
par heure par sophie qui est soulevé
également par le livre d'isabelle
saporta justement non mais je crois
qu'elle ait des tests qui fait pas jouer
à nouveau je sais que le rémora
remarquable livre que je sais que ça a
toujours été le programme je me rappelle
de denis kessler qui était l'ancien
patron des élèves me disait il faut
défaire méthodiquement le programme du
grossier national de la résidence
finalement c'est un petit peu la raison
est développé dans le livre je créais
dire que la planification étatique a
donné à la france la sécurité sociale
qui lui je pense envié dans le monde
entier le peut sans doute le meilleur
système de réseau ferré au monde qu'une
énergie
qui est la moins chère des pays d'europe
de l'ouest icône est en train de
détruire et et qu'on entend détruire
parce que oui il ya plus de
planification le nucléaire par exemple
c'était la planification la une des
moins chères d'europe de l'ouest
une des plus décarbonés enfin je veux
dire mais même géré même au delà même
avant la république le rôle de l'état la
france est un pays qui les ont
construits par l'état vous et vous vous
croyez pas l'économie de l'offre par
exemple mais en fait à mon avis le débat
il n'est pas aussi schéma type que ça il
n'ya pas l'économie de l'offre
l'économie de la demande mais juste par
exemple sur la crise du coc vite parce
que c'était la question que vous posez
c'est est-ce qu'on entre protéger
l'économie
aujourd'hui il n'ya que l'état je vais
proposer
je n'ai pas posé la question n'est que
leurs gains non closes à investir sur
cinq ou dix ans les entreprises ont des
obligations de profit de rendre des
comptes à leurs actionnaires
la seule entité économique qui est
capable de faire des projets à long
terme est de donner de la confiance et
de penser à l'intérêt général qui n'est
pas la somme des intérêts particuliers
c'est l'état alors on peut critiquer sa
gestion moi j'aurais plutôt tendance à
dire que à mon avis le fait de vouloir
gérer l'état comme une entreprise
c'est une idéologie qui a été très en
vogue à partir des années 70 80
ça fait beaucoup de mal à l'état et
c'est une logique qui est porté par tous
les chefs des lizards jamais été produit
on sait pas comment ça peut faire dix
mois aujourd'hui tous les chefs
d'administration de haute administration
mais est-ce que cela vous disent que
vous sauvez vous dise office et il ya ce
discours mais en fait dans les faits ça
n'a pas été fait comme si moi je vous
dis il inverse
si vous regardez toutes les politiques
publiques qui sont mises en place depuis
40 50 ans c'est cette de puiser un
milieu qui est au pouvoir et à mon avis
mais je veux juste finir diable c'est un
petit peu la garde de s'entendre dire
par des gens qui mettent en place ces
doctrines là depuis 40 ans qui ont
conduit à des catastrophes économiques
et sociales de dire voilà c'est à cause
des communistes des bolchéviques
l'étatisme
on a détruit tout ça c'est cette lancée
communisme et vous avez mis vous avez
dit quelque chose d'important
inquiété que on n'avait que l'état était
le seul capable de faire des projets
pour l'économie l'état est incapable de
faire des projets c'est extraordinaire
on ne consulte pas les chefs
d'entreprise que l'état soit capable de
financiers le seul capable de financier
que l'état y va y réfléchir à moyen
terme et à long terme
ce qu'on peut faire ils ne consultent
pas les chefs d'entreprise ne consulte
pas le patronat l'état décrète qu'un
plan de relance personne ne sait ce que
c'est que ce plan de relance qui est
complet oui mais les surveillants peine
financièrement c'est complètement
abstrait le plan de relance moi je
préfère qu'on fasse un plan de relance
pour ceux qui sont mis à leur compte ya
2 millions un million et demi de d'auto
entrepreneur de commerçants qui ferment
de gens qui quittent qui travaillent eux
mêmes qui sont complètement hors du plan
de relance
donc si vous voulez je trouve qu'il ya
une déconnexion reinfo triplette
mandeure du plan de relance est quand
même des exonérations de cotisations
sociales
ah oui ils ont été un peu aidée je suis
indépendante sur l'industrie a eu 20
milliards de ses frères ou sont-ils
année où sont ils allés moi je suis
touché lui payer maintenant je suis
touché par des gens qui disent voilà il
n'avait à l'autre jour j'ai pas payer
mes impôts parce que j'ai plus de
chiffre d'affaires à m'avouer pas payer
vos impôts vous aideront à rien il n'a
plus des deals n'a plus de donc c'est
très compliqué on encore dans des dunes
des connexions deux questions qui sont
posées par les internautes
et je voudrais même si on est dans le
temps additionnel et qu'on est un peu
loin de l'actualité c'est toujours un
sujet quand même qui ceux qui se
reposent c'est pour ça qu'on vous la
proposer ce soit et on vous recommande
la lecture
en tous les cas de
de l'analyse la la chronique de charles
jaigu dans le figaro cette suggestion
qui est fait par interne internautes qui
dit il faut relancer la commande
publique
est ce que vous seriez pouvoir ce que
vous seriez contre relancer la commande
publique c'est pour dire qu'avec
l'argent de nos impôts ou l'argent
qu'ils n'ont pas parce que la dette est
abyssal il commanderait quoi de mon
cours et ben en fait non seulement je
pense que c'est nécessaire mais en fait
je pense qu'il ya un consensus absolu au
sein de toutes les institutions
économiques des économistes aussi
marxiste léniniste que ceux du fmi le 18
c'est ces derniers c'est une ironie je
viens comme sur le web deuxième degré il
faut absolument ils le disent il faut
absolument que l'état prenne en compte
la relance de l'économie et sur le sujet
de la jam pareil le sujet de la dette
la date n'est absolument pas un problème
aujourd'hui alors si le proxy de
solutions variées en tête moi j'ai posé
la question à l'est mais parce que tous
les écoliers cucchi désolé je suis
présentée sans justement l'éloge de la
dette qui s'appelle marc de pelvoux et
alors d'ailleurs elle appartient me dit
écoute les loges la dette était un
problème de la dette est devenue une
solution j'ai dit écoute je voudrais
juste comprendre parce que je ne
comprends plus où est l'argent
ou tu le trouves il me dit ma faciale
n'existe plus haut c'est de la fausse
man et pourquoi veux-tu on ne
remboursera jamais et la seule chose
intéressante sur la dette parce qu'il
n'existe d'internautes la seule
obligation le remboursement des intérêts
de la dette c'est la france qui nous
attendent sous simple que les intérêts
sont négatives la france est dernière
j'étais juste qu'on a on a quand même
flinguer le
l'économie européenne il ya dix ans
venant de l'austérité ce serait bête de
faire une erreur
l'autre question c'est ruiner il s'agit
pas de heurts entre l'austérité et le
panier percé
je ne prône pas le pen et personnes
entre lui et vous prenez vous prenez pas
alors est ce que il ya sept 7 ce que dit
arcus guy que chez lui et je suis
content de vous revoir un certain temps
interventionniste sur les industries
pour les protéger comme les usa d'accord
mais du social à outrance non question
subsidiaire je vous repose la question
différente
est ce que le protectionnisme justement
ne permet pas de protéger les français
s'en faire justement du socialisme ou en
tous les cas de de sacrifier l'économie
pas par le social bon déjà on pourra
voir débat sur le social à outrance je
laisse de côté pour pas prolonger le
temps additionnel je peux vous menez
évidemment que l'europe
enfin les pays européens la france en
particulier à mon avis devrait faire du
protectionnisme bien ciblés comme le
font tous les pays du monde en réalité
et nous sommes le seul pays à ne pas le
faire par idéologie ce fut d'abord il
faudrait que l'europe existe
nous sommes tout à fait nous sommes en
train moi je parle uniquement de la
baisse du travail justement parce que
tous les chefs d'entreprise vont aller
jeter compris les vaccins etc
dans les pays de l'est nous avons une
europe qui complètement inégale donc ça
n'a pas de sens économiquement je suis
désolé de qu'on est en train de deux
policiers pas d'aligner les françaises
sur le salaire des bulgares alors c'est
un sujet je fais c'est un sujet et il va
falloir accords résoudre ce problème
sinon ça n'a pas de sens qu'on raconte
il n'y a pas d'europe sociale possible
n'y a pas d'europe on est tout à fait
d'accord voilà quand même saluer
on est d'accord un immense merci en tous
les cas pour ce débat et pour cette
discussion qu'on a depuis septembre a
qu'un jour tous les quinze jours
à chaque fois c'est avec vous également
bien sûr qui nous regardaient c'est la
dernière de l'année on va se retrouver
en 2021
d'ici là donc le virage manqué de
michèle o est félix torres c'est aux
éditions manitoba alors adrien matou
jouer contre tout contre
enfin vous recommande la lecture parce
que si chargé que vous recommander
à trouver brillantissime c'est que au
moins ça doit être un plaisir pour
l'esprit et tout comme l'est la lecture
des chroniques de charles également
mêlant chant la chute comment la france
insoumise s'est effondré cette
excellence est très intéressant c'est
très documenté et c'est donc le livre
donne rien ma tous et aux et du cacao à
double tranchant il ya tous ceux qui
vont être ravis de la chute et tous ceux
qui disent aux mélenchon pour noël et
non et bien ou bien plus onéreux sur la
shit et bientôt où tous ceux qui
soutiennent jean luc mélenchon qui
croient encore que mélanger et qui se
disent bon comment on s'est planté une
première fois simplement on peut
peut-être c'est une deuxième fois enfin
et ce surtout qui comme moi on aime aime
être informé m comprendre les faits nos
phénomènes voilà
et bien mélenchon la chute c'est aux
éditions du rocher il n'y a pas de jeu
de mots
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
pour le dernier débat de l'année
ici dans le grand plateau vous inquiétez
pas les stream et les live ça continue
toujours sur le site du figaro c'est
figaro live
[Musique]